les jeux de 20h l'émission bien connu de
notre chaîne étaient enregistrés ces
jours derniers à cholet dans le
maine-et-loire plusieurs personnalités
du spectacle participer à ces jeux dont
marcel grandpierre vous révèle les
coulisses
bonjour monsieur
enregistré en public les jeux de 20
heures que suivent chaque soir sur notre
chaîne de nombreux téléspectateurs
mobilise un important matériel et de
nombreux techniciens
au total une trentaine cameramen
électricien machinistes personnel de
réalisation disposant d'une mini
caravane de véhicules techniques car
magnétoscope pour l'enregistrement régie
mobile pour la réalisation car de
sonorisation et véhicules de servitude
après les répétitions du matin trois
jeux sont enregistrées par 12
successivement l'après midi de 13h30 à
19h jeu devant être diffusée la semaine
suivante sur les antennes nationales
chaque semaine enregistrement est
assurée par les moyens régionaux
ainsi retrouve-t-on à cholet faire 3 en
bretagne pays de loire
associé à fr3 lille chargée de la
sonorisation pour toutes les productions
réalisées dans la moitié nord du pays
soler une ville que connaît bien le
célèbre animateur de l'émission
c'est la deuxième fois que nous venons à
cholet et on va bientôt fêter notre
dixième anniversaire des missions et je
me rappelle la première fois que nous
étions venus on est à l'extérieur on a
eu beaucoup beaucoup de monde c'était
devant le syndicat d'initiative et on
avait été très très bien reçus par la
municipalité ce qui veut dire que nous
allons renouveler
voilà notre venue c'est avec beaucoup de
plaisir que ça m'a choqué des jeux qui
attire toujours les foules
bah oui vous avez jugé vous avez vu on a
à peu près de 1000 personnes aujourd'hui
donc je pense que c'est un succès
comment trouvez-vous le public de cholet
très bien très très bien très jeune
dynamique sympa cette fois le juge
arbitre m capello avait pour invités et
christian marin en tournée à cholet
julie bataille et j'aurai mon invité qui
pose les questions auxquelles doivent
répondre les candidats côté variété des
artistes de paris parmi lesquels faire
le client venu avec son dernier tube
voilà ici j'ai
bonsoir mesdames on sort une demoiselle
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir strasbourg et
bonsoir martin europe stocks
bonsoir maurice et bien ce soir nous
allons encore essayer de faire grossir
de petit cochon rose et pour ce faire
nous vous proposons un petit régime
alsacien à base de choucroute deux foies
gras et j'en passe pour la
première émission des jeux de 20h nous
jouons avec bordeaux bonsoir bordeaux
bonsoir jean pierre et bien bon selon
jacques seuls laissent beaucoup de monde
en effet dans notre studio de notre
station régionale bordeaux d'ailleurs
ils vont faire un petit peu de bruit
pour rien qu'on voit qu'ils sont tous là
voilà qui sont déjà été sélectionnés ils
sont prêts à jouer de nombreux nombreux
juges sont en pleine forme et nous avons
dans lol par contre d'autres candidats
qui attendent d'être sélectionné en
compagnie de dan et d'obélix en noël
enfin dominique bonsoir jacques ça va
très bien d'ailleurs vous allez entendre
la voix de but bordelais tout va bien
dominique quand elle m'a bien nous
sommes prêts également dans le studio ce
soir nos candidats vont jouer avec
micheline dax par micheline avec jan
valtin habitudes et applaudit lui même
la nouvelle rocade
alors là maintenant un grand moment de
cette émission je vous demande un peu de
silence un peu de recueillement je vous
présente maître capello si si si si
c'est lui-même capello arbitre du beau
langage trésorier et juge unique de
cette édition
maître capello candidats de bordeaux
maître capello a sélectionné pour vous
une phrase d'un auteur connu cette
phrase vous allez devoir la reconstituer
en fin d'émission mais pour avoir le
droit de la reconstituer vous allez
subir quelques épreuves préliminaires
cette phrase nous la regardons ensemble
elle vaut mille francs pour l'instant
elle comporte 8 mo le lait est et est
bien entendu cinq autres mots et chaque
candidat qui trouvera un mot de cette
phrase est bien fera augmenter la valeur
de cette phrase de 1000 francs donc pour
l'instant elle vaut mille francs nous y
reviendrons tout à l'heure et nous
espérons que les candidats vont faire
grossir la valeur de cette phrase et on
peut empocher le contenu du petit cochon
rose de jacques capelovici qui est d'ici
si vous avez des idées mais chelem
jean-robert surtout ne vous gênez pas
pour qu'à leur offre des millions
d'euros les deux membres voilà et bien
pour l'instant
commençons notre sélection avec un
premier jeu
dominique oui voilà la candidate est en
place à ce que je vois oui c'était les
jolies florence souhaitons lui ai
demandé son prénom
non pardon flanc à sa merci mme joly
dans le 7 10 mais je veux m'excuser
j'avais compris fleurs fleuret bien
bonsoir et bienvenue en france vous avez
lu ce matin dans le journal sud ouest le
mot calumet au pluriel comme celui qui
est affichée là bien entendu et nous
avons eu tout le temps de vous prépare
maintenant micheline dax va tenter de
vous faire deviner un mot issu des
lettres de calumet en vous proposant une
définition de son truc nous sommes bien
d'accord
oui bien alors attention nous jouons
pour deux minutes top chrono
michel c'était alors florence je vais
tout de suite commencer par un mot
difficile parce que je suis très
alléchant je vais prendre un mot de six
lettres carrément ça vous gêne pas j'ai
alors un mot de six lettres et je vous
dis ceux de charlie chaplin ont fait de
l'or
charlie chaplin ont fait de leur une
autre définition
alors je vous dis dangereux sur la route
laurence dangereux sur la route
combien de lettres si la saucisse
également d'une troisième définition
alors toujours au pluriel un casse
toujours quand on est pressé
grâce au toujours comme on est pressé
alors être chiant 2 3 florent je suis
désolé vous n'êtes pas sélectionné mais
vous gagnez tout de même deux places de
cinéma gratuites dans un cinéma de votre
choix à bordeaux alors candidat s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît des lacets
des lacets bien non
un autre candidat est en place oui bien
sûr madame votre nom alors un mot de
trois lettres
madame son histoire a défrayé la
chronique
c'est une histoire a défrayé la
chronique une autre définition micheline
la réponse coule de source madame nac
nac
non non c'est pas eu notre lot willow
oui madame vous êtes sélectionné bravo
vous avez très bien le style et
jean-pierre et vous avez d'ores et déjà
gagné 53 bonsoir très vite et une autre
définition pour essayer de ces normes
un mot de trois lettres une peut-être
gros ouf un autre définition on ne
souffle pas peut-être alors une autre
vie empêche les l'esprit n'en manque pas
top c'est terminé et bien je suis désolé
jeune homme nous avons terminé le temps
qu'ils étaient imparties fédération
comme le jeu vous allez me donner le
goût bien sûr je les ai mis des lumières
c'est le sel c'est le sel bien entendu
eh bien m nous allons sélectionner je
vois ainsi sur une seule personne qui
tout à l'heure en fin d'émission
participera à la fin à la phrase de
maître capello
merci micheline de vous avez
parfaitement jouer je vous félicite pour
bien passer tout près de dominique que
sandra elle passons maintenant à note
et bien sûr generali perdant jardin
c'est pas sympathique pilotage dans
l'es6 après jour elle m'a d'abord je
vous dirais un an s'il est une marie qui
vous mène en bateau
[ __ ] oui monsieur
eh bien monsieur voyez vous la voyez
dire hier
voilà c'est tout simple jean-pierre oui
je vais faire tirer tout d'abord maurice
la carte temps oui je fais tirer à
françoise allez allez voilà tu ne
regardes pas merci voilà la regarder
mais c'est pas grave elle ne joue pas
est la menace alors j'ai bon chrono m jl
siffler la mi-temps je suis flore et
voilà nous sommes prêts maurice c'est
parti sansan alors monsieur ait de boeuf
de boeuf un clin d'oeil klein 208
fabrique perdrix trois coups d'oeil pour
4,4 au pied bon oeil
bonbons 5 550
alors monsieur hyde de lynx 26 vague de
baisse déjà dit elle elle pourrait y
pour oeil 7 762 judas 8,8 dans le faire
et au beurre noir mais ces manoeuvres
d'un day by day in day with you et
d'accolades mais discrètement sans que
très bas oui clin d'oeil dès jeudi déjà
dit ça de grenache lieux fermés
je peux dire yeux aussi les yeux fermés
c'est une expression courante
je vois trop bien je la prends quand
même c'est bon t'as fumé l'ex dès jeudi
déjà dit madame 250 et de bi bush
oui 12 2 205 alors lancé on va rester
maintenant et je sens un canton très
bien de rester cacher et à 207 et pour
gagner plus de 250 mais on peut aller
beaucoup plus loin vous avez la
définition de ces charmants le grand
embouteillage à nous amuser d'etam en
soir ça ne mange pas monsieur gobeil
si vous vous demandez tout ambiancé
monsieur qui peut rester les blâmes à
alhama pour l'instant les yeux dans les
yeux
excellent 14 ainsi vous monsieur pour
l'instant garder là malgré haye pour
elle dès jeudi déjà dit monsieur il
prochain excellent pour cet instant mon
oeil très bonne figure attention rien de
trop de mal à un pied bon oeil
dès jeudi déjà dit lin d'oeil le blonde
aux yeux bleus l'oeil d'un court 16 16
madame calanques qui l'ont cher c'est un
label monsieur de perdre et des jeux cij
à 10 255 cm au sommet du col v jeudi
déjà dit d'amour de sa queue de cheval
se dit malade 9 peter ses valeurs ses
valeurs vite vite vite monsieur sur le
rendement du bund parfaitement 10
octobre c'est bien celle-là il pas utile
non
mon de trois lettres et goûter bien
adolescents admirateur de sylvie martin
de sheila de maurice aviaire de ringo et
de mettre cap et nous valent franchement
qu'est-ce que j'ai devant moi un homme
ou une femme
ça y est je me suis ainsi lettres l et
d'eau douce sur fond vaseux la tâche oui
bravo joué seulement 50 secondes en
quatre lettres petit rapporteur quatre
lettres années comme un hymne années non
non c'est bon c'est l'écho et bien voilà
c'est la joie naturellement pas répéter
robert lohr quatre lettres écoutez moi
bien quatre lettres on peut avoir une
tête à sa tuque annoncé pas sinon il n'y
a pas de nom c'est difficile à écrire
turc avec fantoches on peut avoir une
tête à ça avec quatre lettres sortie
d'une fente auch mais je continuerai à
café non non stop terminé à terminer en
hausse
on peut avoir une tête à nos soyons
moi j'ai lausannoise et je vous garde
vont vous donner des chiffres plus
facilement ce mal être jean pierre
vigato chômage parce que c'est pierre si
je de moyens légaux de l'ère lagarde l'a
bien on compte généralement plutôt ça
empruntant pour une jolie et jeune femme
comme vous j'ai pas compris on va peut
être la vapeur une jeune et jolie femme
on préfère dire un printemps en deux
lettres les a enfin un nom acquis
maintenant je me suis bonjour monsieur
en trois lettres ce facile plus chaud à
amiens et dans bien d'autres villes
une fois c'est une abréviation de soi
trois violentes
oui des 23 points chauds amiens monsieur
trop tard c'est avoue bernard sac en
cinq lettres même fâché je me suis dit
yes i media alors entre bâle est en
athlète à mâcher les gens sont mis en
quatre lettres en quatre ans quatre led
mais c'est pas grave y'a standing
je tiens je tient en quatre lettres 300
pour les petites marionnettes
ça donne son nom à cette lettre tagués
et tu avances à canal et oui mais c'est
pas encore ça marche ça des gens bien
bravo bernard messieurs bonsoir des
traîtres deux banques ont à sans
ordonnance comme en quatre lettres
d'autant qu'on a sont autant de noms ce
cachet tout à fait éclater les villages
étaient sans merci où café encore cinq
enfants
eh bien c'est fini car il élimine eric
bon prix s'est terminée avec ce monsieur
pour arrondir j'espérais bien le désir
de retrouver
voilà maintenant qu'apple ont fait les
frais des scellements saint perdon et
très aisées gagnant ce qui est excellent
pour un lundi
je trouve que c'est fort bien joué bien
voici donc tout de suite et sans tarder
notre deuxième jeu
alors ces petits cochons maître capello
va nous en parler bonbons ce pays quand
il ya mille fois sauf que vendredi
dernier à rodez il a disparu il s'est
envolé en fait l'argent j'étais dans une
nouvelle phase
donc aujourd'hui le ruthénois vous offre
une france entièrement nouvelle et vous
gâte
elle contient 15 nous dont six sont déjà
connus la russie comme l'est celui de
2001 connu deux plus deux autres nous
ont plus un mot là encore un mot inconnu
des suivis de trois mois ont également
ignoré
nous écoutons à vos questions bonjour m
bonjour messieurs il y at il le devait
être dans la phase écouté il y à
monsieur le verbe être je donne 100 fois
aux personnes
naturellement je suis ma phrase oui dans
sept mois quand les grand footballeur de
saint-etienne iront en finale la france
dès sportifs sera contente nice que je
suis là j'ajoute ni le froid et vous
gagnez 50 francs mais à l'époque et du
solo c'est bien parti là en 2005 qui
brille sans lensois auront monsieur
madame c'est à vous bonjour madame
y at il un verbe futur s'il vous plaît
dans cette phase il doit me donne dans
cette phrase verbaux futur voici saint
front sur deux porcelets 2002 quand les
aimables animateur de télévision seront
en vacances la plupart des
téléspectateurs seront très triste
ces gens dit seront plus c'est tellement
vrai gentil et les charmantes la base la
dame
merci madame 2002 bonjour à vous bonjour
m est-ce qu'il ya le mans seront dans la
phrase est de poser une question de
notre stylo rouge 0 l'heureux est ce
qu'il ya là est ce que la phrase
comporte des enfants il n'ya pas
d'hommes d'enfants dans ceux des phases
toujours dans nos décisions
est ce qu'il ya un sentiment dans la
phrase il n'est pas la même question de
sentiments des moindres face une phrase
sanction est ce que il ya une expression
de joueurs dans la phrase cette phrase
non monsieur 2002 toujours aux côtés
mais bonjour m papillon
est ce que dans votre phrase il ya un
nom de ville
il n'y a pas de nom de ville hélas dans
cette phrase 2002 montrent un pape
tandis que john kristian dahl jamais
dans notre france je touche deux verbes
il ya deux verbes dans cette phrase
ajoutent 500 2300 quand les choses sous
un fond de france sur l'otan vacances
la tâche des maîtres sera terminé il ya
de nouveaux madame et la salle arvest en
2003 bien gens soient bien sûr y at-il
un rapport quelconque avec notre région
il n'ya aucun rapport madame hadja
région de picardie jours m bonjour
monsieur
est-ce qu'il ne s'en rappelle que la
famille s'il vous plaît avec la famille
monsieur non 2003 les questions sur le
sens monsieur y at il un nom commun dans
la phrase il y a un nom commun je n'ai
pas dit à ce jeudi
colin naturellement médecin frais pour
le port seul 2004
2 unis je n'ai dit maître capello qui
vous salue lille bonsoir m catania
s'annulent il est bonne appétit alors
maître capello est l'homme du jour
aujourd'hui et espérons qu'il sera
l'homme de la semaine pour lille de
toute façon avec son petit porcelet qui
contient 22 2700 francs à portée de main
des lillois et des lilloises premier jeu
on sent maurice bonsoir tout le monde
est là nous retrouvons aujourd'hui
adéquat mais chantal au soleil de monte
carlo
voilà travail pas tant que ça maurice
actuellement le temps devient menaçant
monte carlo il est temps que l'émission
se termine en été merci monsieur
demain nous jouerons avec le mot
archives oui au pluriel reportez vous
comme chaque jour à votre quotidien nice
matin
j'espère que vous serez nombreux au
rendez vous toujours le même je suppose
toujours devant les terrasses du casino
de monte carlo
bonne fin de soirée à tous et à demain
au revoir andré pulsions
s'est pas trompé alors lequel des trois
de paule baudoin de jacques poids va
vous donner la bonne version 2 attention
du mot mauviette m à uv au 2t savez tous
bien sûr ce qu est une mauviette est ce
pas jean pierre peu mais nous avons un
premier candidat il a pas l'air d'avoir
comme ça il ya imposant 1 700 titres
monsieur oui oui les sports pratiqués
vous emballe en bas c'est tout oui ma
peau de ce qui l accusait alors du skate
oui zaoui également très bien monsieur
donc on écoute vos trois définitions
sont à choisir la bonne monsieur voilà
alors la première définition de monsieur
l'origine un projet de mauvais tous
étonnés par paul préboist alors le mot
mauviette et est apparue au 16e siècle
c'est un diminutif de mots vis mon fils
on appelait movis les alouettes n'est ce
pas huppé au moyen-âge dans nos 'rien'
alouettes superviser la movie ce joli
mot vie mais quand il y avait des ports
ou petite alouette huppé quitté jeunes
donc chétive malingre un peu sous
porteuse maladie quand movie ce n'est ce
pas par l'extension en diminution en
dise et mauviettes unique ça s'est
transporté après quand on a vu quelqu'un
de faible de deck et mauviettes rachète
une mauviette
mais la véritable origine c'est viennent
de ce mot movis qui désignait les
alouettes huppé au moyen-âge et en le
transformer en mauviette pour parler
d'une alouette et qui était peu cher du
bâti de noël un peu chère suzanne c'est
à vous
tout semble séparer la larme à l'oeil
non en réalité c'est un mot d'origine
latine
ça vient du môme alsace et un an de
plantes
c'est une plante qui était mauvais
qu'avait la propriété de soigner à peu
près toutes les maladies les maladies de
tous les malades qui étaient des gens
totalement chétif fatalement souffreteux
est le nom de cette plante est devenu
d'abord move est parce que les thèmes
moraux et jolie et puis après ça s'est
transformé en mauviettes
avec sa s'approchait des à la fois des
malades et de la plante donc c'est une
plante d'origine latine ça n'a rien à
voir avec les alouettes
du fait de pré bois voyez vous voilà
donc maintenant la troisième origine
celle de jacques blanc viennent c'est
pas du tout du latin c'est un mot du
vieil anglais mov et qui veut dire
maigre et qui signifiait et qui fut
repris par les français qui ajoutèrent
le diminutif est synonyme de petit et
qui donna par la suite personnes maigres
chétive mauviettes
voilà je récapitule pour vous si vous
voulez bien monsieur alors pour paul
préboist vient du diminutif movie ce qui
était le nom de l'alouette huppé au
moyen-âge et les petites alouettes huppé
et on les a appelés ensuite des mauves
hier c était tout petit susan gabrielle
au vient du latin malva qui voulait dire
mauvais puis ensuite mauvais tu es puis
mauviette c'était une plante qui servait
à soigner les personnes malades et pour
jacques prébois n'est pas d'accord du
tout avec ses deux partenaires vient du
vieil anglais mao qui signifie maigre
alors qu' à la bonne origine des trois
au hasard la 2 ouazar l'a26 taire susan
gabrielle au cheval cabré
non mais c'est pas ça du tout c'était
pour pas que c'est vraiment le j étais
bien en réalité
en réalité ces pôles prévoir j'avais la
bonne réponse assurée n'y a ni
végétal j'étais du règne animal ma vie
c'était vraiment du mas pas tout
recommencer
c'est effectivement l'alouette une peiné
que le monde y est rassurant pour finir
jean pierre chalas le bailleur j'espère
que ça va s'arranger
alors
saucissons j format de papier très
simple lettre j agis juliette ont ceci
son format de papier le jésus jésus
blement représentation du christ enfants
et les nourrissons un jésus ceux ci sont
de lyon par excellence 50 points la
lettre t monsieur emery ces lyonnais
vous presse presque d c'est un nom
sensations produites par le contact
mécanique d'un objet ou encore sentiment
délicat des convenances de la mesure le
tact revient 60 points je pense que nous
continuer monsieur jean à lèvres eu
comme cursus on continue il s'agit ici
monsieur d'un nom je vous le donne
groupe d'écoles nommé suivant les pays
faculté au collège que dix universités
et dispensent l'enseignement supérieur
70 points le cieux à la lettre v
autrement dit le score de marie
christine vos pierres et battus qui
était de 70 points la lettre x
vous avez donc monsieur les deux mille
francs à portée de votre main ils sont
chez vous dans votre portefeuille déjà à
on continue vous configurez traits d'un
verbe e enlevé remporté un avantage à la
guerre ou la portée sur bakr ni 80
points w monsieur vous continuez en
continu continu et le w n'est pas le
plus dur il ya très peu de mots dans le
dictionnaire ayant w pour initial
comprenait le mot évidemment d'origine
étrangère et que devient mon anglais jeu
de cartes ancêtre du bridge et cetera
venez ici il ya du feu voilà vous avez
vos questions oui bon alors on va les
écouter avant vous allez donner votre
nom et votre prénom madame alors thérèse
michel bon est bien madame vous savez
vous pouvez vous arrêter à la cinquième
question bonne chanson vous écouteront
selon michel gestion bonsoir vous pouvez
me dire si vous étiez un livre qu est ce
que vous seriez aux abeilles vous
commencez bien là alors là félicitations
car je suis un livre en vérité je suis
en revenant sur un personnage de roman
pour m appeler mon père bien que ce ne
soit pas dans les ordres
et si vous étiez un prénom je peux vous
le dire je ne crois pas que ça vous
aidera beaucoup mais je peux vous le
dire jean joachim ou jacques m sanya que
tu appelles aux villes ce qui peut vous
dire comment en prenant à dives et
sommes allés bitume
si vous étiez le métier aulas je vais
vous surprendre parce que je peux
répondre de façon très précise
je serai négociants et négociants
écoutez bien ça c'est très précis alors
dans le commerce du vermicelle des pâtes
d'italie et de l'amidon
c'est très précis un missel d'ehpad
italie et de l'amidon dans la farine
oeufs chère madame je fais dans le
farine date c'est pas ça une date vous
essayez de situé au 1800 1830 33 ans oui
je crois 33 en tout cas c'est ça
jusqu'à maintenant j'arrive pas bien
haut mais j'ai un quartier le quartier
latin quartier latin non quand même pas
vous apporter grand chose je passe un
très bon sens justement c'est pour ça
que je pense que vous n'avez pas situer
dit qu'on va redemander une autre
question vous pouvez gagner 500 francs
là mais c'est un peu juste arriver là je
n'ai pas trouvé ça mais si vous étiez un
surnom le père art dont le père le frère
le père le faire le père a le père
pardon et si vous étiez une passion une
passion rouge avec une passion vous
savez ce sont mes filles ce sont mes
deux filles voulaient que je donne des
précisions oui bon alors j'ai une fille
que j'ai marié au compte de restons et
l'autre au financier new single ne sais
pas comment pour longtemps encore le
single c'est bien ce sont les méchants
d'ailleurs vous savez que je vous
préviens mes filles sont très méchante
parce qu'elle ne sent même pas venu à ma
mort a volontairement travail et je
commence un peu dans sa villa 7e
question il ya 300 francs a gagné un
personnage d'un roman de balzac or là je
vous avais les précisions je précise 10
autres en cas de trop sérieux
tous le disent
et maurice et bien moi je voudrais pour
terminer ces jeux vous présenter un
nouveau chanteur nous avons rendu
hommage à tout le monde sauf à un
personnage vous l'avez deviné nous
allons faire maintenant
et pour ce faire je vais vous présenter
un personnage dont c'est le début dans
la carrière de la chance on le voit
c'est il a peur il est très influent me
laisser jean pierre descombes
il va vous interprétez sur une musique
de monsieur 100 lycées sur des paroles
de jean pierre descombes et de marc
menant une toute nouvelle chanson qui
j'espère va faire un tube à vous pour
terminer cette émission anniversaire
avoue jean-pierre merci
avec son vieux dico rap et ils arbitrent
les jeux télévisés
me natali rigolo capello
il y a qu un jour par semaine qu'ils
nous pondent la troisième cherchent le
dimanche à bangolo capello
heureusement qui al'intérêt
en eau permet de l'admirer
ce zorro du petit litre
tu sais
capello
derrière son vieux dico et
on voit de droit se dressèrent
eureka le moment trouvé
soir en
on s'attend
ces jeux de mots de montauban saint malo
capello
les dimanches sont bien monotone je
dirais mais pour son opposant sans le
visage de 50 jours tu sais
capello dans son vieux dico et
ces trois villes une épopée
il fait mouche comme l'ont seulement
tous les grands de la politique de
gauche de droite quand il était
il voudrait être aussi fait que je sais
c'est qu'on
dire que j'ai passé des années
à côté de lui qu'elle destine on a joué
pas tous les jours tu sais
neo 2
j'aurais pu c'était pas mal hein
les gâcher son chemin
il aurait été de chars lourds capello
son paradis c'est le latin
de la grand mère c'est le lutin
il aura toujours un sur vingt deux très
bien
maintenant avant deux parties
laissez moi encore dire
le dico et bien pâlot
sans toi
capello
heureusement qu'à la télé
pour nous permettre de l'admirer
ce zorro du petit littré
capello
pâtissant demandons à daniel prévost de
nous faire oublier cette tristesse avec
un jeu fou et donc on ne quitte pas la
maladie pour un adjectif jean-pierre
voilà avec les filles j'ai un succès fou
jean-pierre s'il disait alors souhaité à
20 heures alors oui des fois je me
trompe de chansons là vous allez donc
jouer maintenant madame à l'adjectif
vous allez poser des questions à daniel
pour découvrir un adjectif d'achat
d'accord voilà alors un bon moment en
perspective avec les amis allez vous
après cette première question à les hits
et puis vous sortir les soirs
comment répéter aimez vous sortir le
soir
avez vous avez vous trouvé de bonne
distraction à charleroi
aimez vous les jeux de 20 heures
etes-vous parfois sérieux de distraction
favorite
quels sont vos distractions favorites
vous sentez vous proches les amis non
vous sentez vous proche des animaux
aimez vous les vacances c'est fait s'il
vous plaît il ya lieu de souligner qu'il
a eu la classe de batterie qui est
intervenu
on en croit pas du tout à plat ce n'est
pas un jeu fou et pourtant ça commence
par un b et au total il ya cette lettre
alors b et c'est peut-être oui on le
croyait et y en a c'est pas tout à fait
juste bien madame c'est en egypte
je vais laisser le plateau mon ami paul
préboist vous êtes d'accord amis cogolin
alors on va cueillir paul paul préboist
mon cher paul vous allez en effet nous
mi mai alors non pas des animaux non pas
des métiers des titres de films mais ce
sont des sentiments
c'est un homme sensible on va vite vous
regardé et on va essayer de trouver à
chaque fois les sentiments ni mais par
paul préboist paul préboist alors
regardez bien dans un ami paul madame
votre réponse
la joie la joie oui
deuxième sentiment quand vous voulez
paul on va demander à jean je t'aime de
resserrer un peu sur le visage de paul
préboist agents cohen merci regardez
bien notre ami paul alors je devrais pas
sourire d'ailleurs mademoiselle
attendait alors comment est il la
tristesse la tristesse
mon cher paul nous reportons avec vous
allez au début
regardez bien monsieur la douleur la
douleur ça fait rire paul préboist
regard des bons recherche peut alors pas
encore avec vous la petite liste il faut
pas se tromper paul
attendez continue et peut-être pas
encore un petit peu pour que dans
téléspectateurs puissent jouer chez eux
également
mais j'aime bien vous voir comme ça
c'est rare qu'on voit comme ça dans la
vie
alors comment est il né coléreux oui
c'est la colère regardez bien à alors
qu'ils la pensée non c'est pas tout à
fait la bonne réponse et qui le rêve non
alors paul il faut donner la réponse oui
je refais pour montre est à c'était la
douceur on peut revoir la douceur paul
regardez bien vous voulez revoir la
douceur avec plaisir à ses breaks et de
la douceur c'est vrai pas le bravo paul
encore un sentiment animé par paul
préboist
la peur la peur oui et le coup de
sonnette en même temps mon cher paul
voilà après la peur qu est-ce qui a et
bien c'est la sortie car c'est fini
merci moment paul salle très bonne bien
france région croît bienvenue en
province à châlons sur marne en
champagne bonsoir à tous et à toutes
et nous allons commencer par premier jeu
n'est ce pas monsieur points
eric bouin alors vous avez réalisé cet
objet qu'on appelle une fille violante
à quelle occasion et pourquoi voilà la
question que nous posons aux invités de
notre ami marc menant pourquoi cette
fine yolanthe fabriqués par monsieur
bouin
première question à vous trouver la
réponse non non c'est de la danse où je
tressé de mes mains est ce que c'est un
genre de gars au nom parce que ça sert à
frapper quelqu'un rouvrir un petit peu
après la frappe est à sa 4ème être
humain oui à frapper un être humain
c'est une salle de 6000 de deux cas elle
se fout et une quelque chose que les
moines se met pour se donner pénitence
non sinon c'est pour frapper à l'être
humain
oui une femme donc pas une folie mal un
homme
oui d'accord un homme attend ils
tiennent une femme aussi une femme ou un
homme mauvaise image qui me semblait
hommes et femmes ou hommes et ces femmes
ça n'a aucune importance si c'est
l'importance non c'est pour le punir non
plus un ancien nom c'est un moyen de
torture pas du tout c'est tout à fait ça
ça on peut s'en servir maintenant on
s'en sert encore pour vous le frappez
pour le plaisir non par qui on n'offre
pas très fort en voudraient s médical
non plus on assiste là il ya des
connaisseurs non ce n'est pas pour le
plaisir on fera pas très fort s'est
posée je sais pas moi c'est pour que
pour faire circuler le sang ah non mais
faut frapper on fera pas très fort il
faut attacher
non il faut que la tâche et on fera
seulement fera pâle mais ça sert à ça
c'est ça son ménage fonctions non ce
n'est pas pour la défense les sas mais
ça fonctionne que pour frapper où ça
rien d'autres usages
c'est un usage symbolique un message
symbolique
je signale quand même que patrick ou non
il ya douze minutes parce qu'il a sonné
oui bah oui depuis que vous savez qu
éventuellement que ce soit pour le
plaisir
bon ben vous allez savoir monsieur pour
200 francs dit le tout alors éric bouin
à quelles raisons pourquoi avez vous
fabriquez donc cette fine yolanthe
expliquez nous alors je suis d'abord
élève à l'école nationale supérieure des
arts et métiers de châlons sur marne et
il y à une période d'initiation et cette
année d'initiation se termine au bout de
deux mois d'entrer à l'école et j'ai
fabriqué de mes mains
cette fine yolanthe qui sert à fignoler
la tenue que l'on a
le jour du baptême des premières années
voilà donc la réponse alors attendez
attendez on va maintenant vous le dire
qu'un hasard et en étant d'état pendant
la cérémonie je crois je pense savoir
qu'à un moment donné on frappe avec non
voilà pendant la cérémonie le signe du
baptême
ça se rapproche un peu du glaive du
chevalier
avez vous nous faire une démonstration
la voilà on va voir un petit peu ce que
ça donne son championnat
alors attendez imaginons c'est le jour
de votre baptême cher monsieur c'est
mieux voilà regardez bien comme ceux ci
interdit mettez vous un petit peu de
profil qu'on va bien le mouvement et
comment vous frapper alors allez-y à la
fête voir
dépêchons nous voilà il faut quelqu'un
qui soit genou donc envers le conserver
allez-y regardez bien voilà voilà
pourquoi on frappe
attendez j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
ingénieur un jour alors allez-y
doucement un moment allez-y
voilà cette fine yolanthe pour nos
ingénieurs de l'école des arts et
métiers trois ans d'école et le diplôme
d'ingénieur
c'est une tradition qui est quasiment
centenaire puisque le centenaire sera
fêté à champs-sur-marne l'an prochain
merci messieurs on vous applaudit encore
une fois bravo
roux voilà bien nos invités viennent
d'arriver pour l'instant ils sont de dos
car il regarde la corbeille
alors je voudrais vous demander nous
avons le temps de faire un humiliant
jean-pierre le temps une fois nous avons
eu tant que vous êtes d'accord les
monégasques oui bon alors je vais
demander aux invités de se retourner je
vais on commence avec evelyne je vais
vous laisser mon micro yvelines alors
pas de oui pas de nom pendant une minute
et chacun votre tour d'accord voilà j'ai
choisi qui je veux donc à bon passe
dessous non rester là vous restez là
yvelines voile il va jouer dans la fri
et les pets la peau fille alors on va
jouer au milan avec evelyne qui veut
commencer
madame vous vous levez miss l'avez vous
pas de wii pas de nom pendant une minute
d'evelyne quand vous voulez bonjour
madame bonjour madame
mais vous avez mis un manteau vous avez
un peu froid dit oui madame alors
j'aurai suivant la carlos peut-être que
dans bonjour madame louis on voit alors
qui veut jouer avec carlos l'avait
travaux a largement à vos wii avec quart
d'once pas de wii pas de nom pas de nom
bonjour l'homme ça fait plaisir
alors si vous attends je vais descendre
sim gelée par là bas on prend une
candidate pour d'autres amis sim
une dame de préférence six mois pas
toujours bien sûr madame z joue avec sim
allez venez là pour lui pas de nom c'est
parti madame bonjour madame donc
huissier bonjour madame vous voulez vous
avez failli tomber la presse qu avant
vous allez bien ça va est ce que vous
croyez que le ciel va se maintenir ont
je crois notre beau soleil
vous avez dit oui non
et bien non je pense que nous n'avons
plus le temps maintenant 1
alors nous allons applaudir encore une
fois nos invités evelyne grandjean
carlos sim et je me demandais à régis
forissier le dernier quart pendant
l'émission
régis nous n'avons pas le temps de
laisser la parole à jean pierre foucault
devant les championnes tellement malin
et ferati ralliera pas ces violences le
malade est votre candidat
oui les gens attendent et je crois qu'il
ya un petit problème ce qui concerne
l'or voulez vous
voila voila c'est moins précis dans ce
qui est bien ce soir c'est que c'est
directement du producteur au
consommateur je paye directement encore
un mois ne pas prononcer et 7 à jean
pierre foucault de vous poser les
questions
jean-pierre avant toute chose je
voudrais remercier les charmantes
hôtesses de l'air qui m'ont permis
d'arriver là intacte bonjour madame quel
est votre nom gabrielle je suis là on
voyait spécialement par le ministre de
la communication pour préparer la
quatrième chaîne alors je pense que vous
allez pouvoir répondre à mes questions
la petite enquête que je vais faire
alors qu'elle est lequel quels sont les
genres d'émissions de vous préférez
généralement la télévision madame il
fallait dire je le mot jeu était prohibé
ce soir
et bien maintenant on va avec une
deuxième candidate je pense nous allons
voir dilate son prénom
josiane josiane à tout ce qu'avait
fiez-vous il est dangereux c'est un mec
gentil qu'il est mondialisée scolaire je
suis envoyé spécialement par le ministre
de l'économie aujourd'hui pour faire un
petit test auprès de la population de
fréjus
en ce qui concerne notamment le calcul
mental entre nous est-ce que vous étiez
très doué en place en calcul mental
pas du tout pas de préférence est-ce que
vous avez des enfants j'en ai deux oui
ici la jeune fille un garçon et un tient
pas facile
3 on va continuer deux fois 5 pour voir
si vous êtes doué 8 le 8 c'est pas mal
du tout 3 x 7 14 14 c'est bien 5 x 4 23
23 un bravo
maître capello en fait je devais vous
faire dire 20 madame a prononcé 20 ans
et elle a gagné la guerre et la gagner
je vois la gueule à gagner c'est maître
capello qui vous donnera les 50 francs
bada est bien la maison evans
m
jean pierre descombes eu le doigt sur la
bouche
mais un autre invité pour qu'on
reconnaisse sa voix et voici tout
d'abord bien sûr l'accessoire
indispensable le petit sifflet ont par
contre vous attention voilà nos amis
sont masquées pas encore après ce que
voilà la saison unis déroule fait c'est
fini c'est prêt patrick topaloff triche
oui il à masquer un oeil là la famille
ses lunettes et moustaches c'est famous
ter la moustache rejoint le match que ça
fait un ensemble assez très bien roulé
cher jean pierre pendant tout de suite
un petit essai avec le siffleur pour
dire oui on s'y fait une fois non deux
fois et bwin une ombre du lait que lui
voilà voilà ce que ça donne bon eh bien
nous sommes prêts à les y bord
questionner moustache michelin j'ai
voulu peuple avait envie à monte carlo
ah ça y est vous danseurs nous vous êtes
un homme ou une femme
est ce que vous êtes un homme c'est
qu'il quitte à nous et c'est peut-être
un petit enfin non c'est un garçon
autonome le reconnaît là s'est même
plaint oui quand même bien à est ce que
vous faites dans le drame monsieur oui
enfin l'acteur sérieux alors demain
mais toi je sais pas moi je ne sais plus
je tourne
est-ce que je vous connais quoi qu'il en
soit ça veut dire très bien branché oui
multiplier à l'avenir oui oui est-ce que
vous connais tous c'est ce qu'on vous
connais tous vous êtes célèbre et j'ai
beaucoup lu ces belmondo elle vaut
actuellement à monter le cal pour le
festival de la télé il aurait donc une
prestation là bas avez-vous le principal
rôle c'est carbet pas du tout
est ce que vous êtes jeunes oui ils
modulent toujours jeune je vous dis toi
monsieur c'est le petit train d'être
abattu le connais personnellement des
impressions est-ce que cela y en a chez
nous est ce que nous d'eux vous vous est
ce qu on vous connaît personnellement
oui mais
on ne connaît pas la table idiot mais
est-ce que j'ai chanté aussi monsieur à
les musiciens oui à moi qui les oui mais
vous n'êtes plus il ya aussi ça veut
dire non
catégorie c catégorie vous êtes sportif
aussi ouais voilà qui modulent vraiment
bien vous pratiquer un sport d équipe
d'avoir entendu une chorale peut-être
que tu as compris chez moi c'est dans le
noir à celle demandée à la alors on va
avoir donné des noms comme ça mais
sottement vous êtes bien obligé d'étaler
pour l'attique le bracelet pas c'est pas
assez drôle toit de rien serieys toi
petit carnet claude brasseur
non c'est paris non non ce projet on a
droit à un sac
alors là il est temps de donner un nom
au moins c'est pas trop ma soeur elle
assiste dans les idées parle-nous moi
j'vais non non non non non
voilà je vais lui offrir le sifflet
d'ailleurs bien ça ne sera que justice
or allégé décision une décision il va
gardois à quoi nos bois ville nommée ni
valeur françois françois son nouveau-né
et micheline bon alors c'est un leader
s'est terminé bien vous pouvez enlever
hommage à regarder puisqu'on attend bien
sûr et j'ai sifflé comme thème michenaud
absolument après écoute chéri enfin à et
je viens de te voir et que j'étais trop
furdi j'appuie que ça veut dire ça non
c'est non non non je les tenais situe
bien comment allez-vous mai aps les
agneaux bas bien pourquoi maintenant ben
oui moi aussi je suis bien content tu
peux passer avant de lui et de sifflet
j'avais envie de te dire tout l'amour et
tout et tout et rien m j'ai senti tout
avait d'ailleurs songé que tu veux faire
avec un truc on peut savoir ce que tu
fais actuellement à monter car oui et
bien vers ce que l'ag des films qui sont
passés qui ont des sélectionnés le
bartleby réalisée par maurice ronet
adapté par jacques warren c est maurice
ronet et puis le film de jacques ertaud
la mer promise qui est passé également
le même jour c'est à dire mardi dernier
et puis alors maintenant on attend des
résultats c'était très très bien
accueillis alors c'est pour ça je suis à
monte carlo ça me fait très plaisir
parce que il fait beau avec un rien un
petit un petit air frais mais très très
très beau s'est fait très beau voilà oui
et alors
je connaissais chantal je connais ces
salles de vue mais bon je ne vous en dis
pas plus mais je ne tiens pas ce que
chantal intentions orientale elle et
elle est vraiment extraordinaire elle
pense bien l'image à les promesses
étaient reprochés alors des projets et
bien les projets et les chanteurs bah ça
j'aimerais bien mais enfin pour
l'instant j'en ai pas enfin les
fiançailles sont en route et sur le plan
de la de la pellicule et bien il y a
une probablement une série de gérard cyr
et maurice closs une série de six films
qui vont s'appeler l'homme
les hommes de roses des hommes de rose
prénom rose est ce qu'on a trop bas
bientôt dans l'équipe des jeux de 20
heures
ah bah ça j'espère aussi ma place est
toujours la même d'accord d'accord on
voit qu'il va mongongu s'agit en tout je
t'ai pas vu max plus nous savons très
bien monsieur top à la fin mon grand
comment tu vas mon patin je veux bien
mais quand je serai content de te voir
et moi aussi ça me fait bigrement
plaisir parce que ça fait justement cup
michel je l' ai vu un petit peu avant
mais là ça me fait spécialement plaisir
parce que nous cachais pas de topalov ça
fait un petit moment je n'avais pas vu
par les sens bien à sa place au chaud
maître capello tu attends aussi avec un
d'accord toujours en forme et la merci
mon avis tu as gagné tu as gagné 50
francs pour un jeune garçon il s'appelle
eric il est d'arriver tout derrière la
côte et voilà bon ben bravo à eric on le
peut on peut l'appeler non il est pas là
non il est derrière dans la foule on le
verra après l'émission alors il a gagné
cinq ans et je suis très content va le
partager avec le petit eric salut à tous
ça lui vaut